What'd it look like?
But it was from all we can tell,
it was awfully close to today's chimps.
And so there,
if you look at chimps today,
you can get a pretty good sense of what life was like then.
And chimps today are really interesting.
They're basically at the top of the food chain in the rain forests.
They,
because they travel in groups,
even amazing tree climbers,
like leopards won't try to attack them in trees.
It's just,
it's,
they're too dangerous,
too fast.
But if you look at a chimp on the ground,
it can't even lock its knees.
It's as kind of cute little stumbling along thing.
And then the question is why would an animal that runs the show in the canopy
leave the rainforest for the Savannah and then how to survive once I did that.
And that's,
that's the story of this book and then how that manifested itself to where we
are today.
So really my goal,
I'm a psychologist.
I want to understand why we are the way we are.
And so in trying to figure that out,
I said,
well,
let's take a look back all the way to our common ancestors and see some of the
key events and how they might have had an influence on how we are today.
So the first question is,
why would we leave the trees right here we are,
we're dominant position where we're food on the ground.
Why would we ever take that risk?
And the basic story there is the great African Rift Valley,
I'm not sure if you've,
you're familiar with that at all,
but basically it runs down from,
I'm up at the Red Sea down to the coast of Mozambique and you can think of it
like a geographic zipper.
You know,
all the world's sits on these tectonic plates and sometimes they crash into each
other like,
uh,
how Indian smashing into Asia and creates amylase.
Sometimes they literally tear apart and Africa's tearing apart at the great
African Rift Valley.
So that plate that has Somalia and Ethiopia,
Tanzania,
Kenya,
that's moving off to the lower right.
The rest of Africa is moving off to the upper left.
And I got no idea why it's been going on for quite a while.
But one of the consequences that is that the east Africa starting to rise up
slowly,
bit by bit,
and when it rises up,
the rain forest dry out.
And so basically what you have is a situation where our ancestors were on the
east side of that Rift Valley and it started to dry out.
And now they're in a situation where they've got this great lifestyle,
their dominant position,
but now they're pushed.
They're forced out onto the ground increasingly more and more because there's
more and more ground and less and less rain forest.
And so how did they survive that?
What do they do in order to make that work?
And this is,
uh,
what,
what period of time is this?
How many millions of years ago,
six or seven,
does this coincide with the when,
when was the jump of the human brain size?
We're double,
we'll get to that.
So it's a super interesting question about why that happened as well.
So basically if you track us across the next 3 million years,
how did our ancestors survive when they're basically chimpanzees on the open
Savannah.
And you can get a hint of how they did it because there's one chimpanzee group
that does live on the Savannah in Senegal and they,
um,
they show some differences between themselves and other chimps that traveled and
slightly larger groups.
They share more nicely with each other,
which is interesting.
That's kind of a human trait as well.
And uh,
they also avoid open space.
Like they are just kind of trying to stay near the trees as much as possible.
And,
and if you look at other aids,
not aids,
but other primates that are on the Savanna,
like Savannah baboons,
they're only monkeys.
So they're not as sharp is chimpanzees are,
but they have a similar strategy,
large groups to try to protect themselves and lots of eyes to look out for
predators.
And they do fine on the Savannah.
And so what I suspect happened is for the first few million years,
basically what you've got is this chimp like animal that's kind of skirting the
edges of Savannah.
Nowhere near the top dominant position they used to be and just kind of noodling
around.
And that takes,
I suspect that takes us for about the first three,
three and a half million years.
And if you look at who we are,
then we're Australopithecus afarensis.
So it's,
if you looked at one of them,
you'd think it belongs in a zoo.
It looks almost like a chimpanzee.
And so a chimp brain,
in answer to the first part of your question is about 380 grams.
And Australopithecus brain is about 450 grams.
So 3 million years of evolution and all we've got four to 70 grams.
So why do we get so smart?
Why do we take off in the next few million years?
And what is it that Australopithecus did that,
that helped us survive?
And,
and why do I call that the social late?
That's all kind of tied together.
And the basic story is it,
by this point Australopithecus has become bipedal and we can talk about how that
happened if you'd like.
And so because they're bipedal,
their waste is now stretched out their,
um,
their musculature.
Like,
if you look at Chimpanzee Pecs,
they aim upward because of course chimps climbing all the time.
Um,
Australopithecus is more lateral like we are,
we're basically completely lateral because things are side to side as far as
we're concerned.
It's harder to climb a tree,
but it's a whole lot easier to do a lot of other things.
And uh,
we have much more limber shoulder,
we have much more limber wrist,
all that sort of thing.
And a lot of that was in place by Australopithecus.
So once they became by peatal,
they gained a lot of these qualities.
And then the question is why do those qualities matter?
Well,
the,
if you watch a chimpanzee throw,
it's terrible at it even though they're stronger than you and I are pound for
pound by a sizable margin.
When they throw their inept,
they can't Dane very well and they typically use two hands because they're not
lined up well to throw.
If you watch a really good thrower,
like you know,
a grid iron football player,
a baseball player or a hunter gatherer throw,
you know it's a full body motion to step forward with the other leg.
There's this rotation and the very last minute you bring your risk through.
Well what that does is it creates an enormous amount of elastic energy across
your muscles,
tendons and ligaments.
And the end of that throw for a human,
it's like the snapping of a rubber band.
So chimps can't do that.
They're not lined up properly.
But australopithecus got to the point where they could probably do that pretty
well.
And so now,
and this is purely a byproduct of bipedalism because it's stretched out their
whole body and they don't,
they're not climbing as much anymore.
So their musculature is more lateral,
which would have been helped them for throwing.
So now you get to a point where they have access to the single most important
military invention in history,
which is the capacity to kill it a distance.
So if you and I are running around the Savannah and Elian attacks us and we got
50 of our best friends,
we could kill it with our bare hands.
But a lot of us are going to die in the process,
right.
Because think 50 of us go,
let's make it a hundred somebody who even though they would,
you know,
with a bunch of Nice and shy,
and I'd be super coffee.
Yeah,
you wouldn't worry people,
you wouldn't worry very much.
But,
but even if we could,
so we knew what we're doing.
We're all armed with knives,
whoever,
whoever goes in his first screwed.
Right.
And so the capacity to kill it a distance though allows a larger force of weaker
individuals to come to easily defeat a stronger individual.
And so once they gained this capacity to throw,
if they were attacked by lions or something like that,
whereas in the past they did just scattered for the trees.
Now they can throw stones at it and defend themselves now and Australopithecus
throwing rocks at alliance is going to be in the belly of a slightly annoyed
line in about three minutes.
Right,
right.
But 50 australopithecines throwing rocks at Lyons is a totally different story.
And so it's the,
this is the idea here is the throwing hypothesis there.
What,
what changed everything was throwing.
And the reason it changed everything is that it caused us,
it was the first reason why we should have any effective collective action
because it's not a good strategy when you're on your own.
It's not a good strategy if I do it in the rest of the group hits heads for the
trees.
But it's a great strategy if we all do it together.
And so for the first time in history,
the group's goals and our history in our line,
the primate line,
the group's goals aligned with the individual goals,
which is let's cooperate and work together to try to drive away these predators.
Now it,
you look at a lion and you look at someone throwing rocks,
it still seems like a really big ask,
right?
To drive that thing away or kill it,
throwing rocks.
And so,
but Barbara Isaac was one of the first anthropologist to propose this hypothesis
quite a while ago.
Went Back and looked through the historical record and these extraordinary
stories of how effective people are throwing rocks.
And so in when the Portuguese went to the Canary Islands to try to subjugate it,
they rock up with,
you know,
armor guns,
uh,
crossbows.
And this is like 14 something and all the locals were on with,
with stones.
And despite the fact that the Portuguese are there in army trained,
you know,
ready to shoot and,
and in their armor,
they were just decimated by the local stone,
Roxanne.
And this story has happened over and over again.
And when you read these accounts,
they're extraordinary.
I can read you some examples from here.
They just,
the,
it happened in Australia.
It happened in the Canary Islands that happened elsewhere.
They just throw rocks incredibly accurately,
incredibly hard and really fast.
Hmm.
So,
and there's,
you know,
accounts in Africa basically killing a zebra with one blow of a rock to the
head.
Hmm.
So like,
uh,
a picture of major league pitcher.
Yeah,
exactly.
Rock.
Right.
Who gets very accurate at it.
So do you think they,
they must have practiced constantly.
What I suspect is that we evolve to like to throw rocks.
And so if I look at,
if you look at my son as a,
for example,
when he was 18 months old,
we would be walking back toward the house.
If he saw a rock on the street,
he picked it up and start trying to throw it.
And my wife said,
no,
don't let him throw rocks.
It's only going to cause trouble.
First of all,
I'm thinking,
well maybe I'll develop a good arm so I'm gonna go ahead and let them anyway.
But it's secondly,
he fricking wants to,
this is like something inherently fun for him,
right?
And I think all humans enjoy throwing and it's,
it's stunning how good you can get it with practice.
So,
um,
we were at the Ohio state fair,
but there's,
before my son was born and I was walking by one of these stalls where you can
throw in a radar gun.
And so I thought I was just starting to date my wife and I thought,
oh,
here's a perfect chance to impress her.
Right?
And how,
how much do I am?
So I said,
hey,
why don't I stop and I'll throw some balls here and this net,
cause I had never thrown,
I didn't know how fast I could.
So she's like,
sure.
And I was,
I played like little league,
right?
So I throw the ball and it's like 50 miles an hour and she's pretty impressed
because that's sounds fast,
right?
Then this like kid shows up next to me,
it's got to be 12 years old,
probably weighs 85 pounds.
There's total gang,
I'm not a muscle in his body.
And he just starts to freaking throw on ball after ball it like 65 miles an
hour.
And I'm like fuck.
I mean she's not going to be impressed with,
it's like human twig next to me is kicking my ass,
right?
And so I pick up the last ball,
I fricking throw it as hard as I can.
It hurts my shoulder,
flies off at an odd angle,
doesn't hit anything,
and it's like 57 miles an hour.
Now,
that little guy who's like literally the size of an hostile Pythagoras was
thrown in 65 and hitting the target every time.
And so it's obvious it,
it's skill,
it's practice that would have made you good at this.
And if your life depends on it,
you're going to do it.
Well,
that makes sense.
Coming from a martial arts background,
like coordinated movement where at the end of it,
you snap exactly sense that this technique is so critical,
even though you're a larger person.
So a better technique could have more of an impact with that.
So the throwing arm,
I had read this and if that was one of the hypothesis,
there's several hypothesis why the human brain doubled over a period of 2
million years.
Another one was cooked meat,
right?
They figured out a way to get more nutrients out of meat that's writing it over
fire,
right?
So that's a little bit down the road.
So here we are three and a half million years ago.
And so for the first time we put some pressure on ourselves to have an advantage
to be smarter.
So imagine you're a zebra.
You know what the hell good is it to you to be Einstein?
You got moves.
What are you going to do with that brain?
Right?
But it's a big,
it's a big cost.
Our brains are 20% of our metabolic energy,
whether we're doing math or watching TV,
it's,
it's constant drain.
And so what are our ancestors?
Why would they pay for that drain?
Now,
just recently,
there was a paper that came out maybe three months ago now on um,
a new brand expansion gene they found or they think that's what it is called to
NL.
And it turns out,
I don't know,
12,
15 million years ago,
there was an accidental duplication of that gene on our genome and it,
but it was ineffective and it just sat there doing nothing.
Now that's a great way that evolution works where it accidentally doubles a gene
because then you don't,
you can mess with it.
And the old jeans still doing the job,
right?
So it sat there for about 9 million years in our line til about 3 million years
ago,
round Australopithecus and then it duplicated itself and it came online again.
And would that gene seems to do is it makes our brain remain as stem cells for
longer,
which means a lot more duplication before they run away and start becoming
neurons.
And so if I had to guess,
I'd say that that probably that gene coming online probably happened many times
in the past and every time it happened in the past it was more cost than it was
worth.
And so what's the chimp going to do with a little bit more brain and just means
more calories and what does he gain from it?
But now that we're working together,
now that we have collective action,
all sorts of things open up,
we could,
we could devise division of labor,
I'll say,
hey man,
you do this and I'll do that.
Cause Australopithecus they've got 70 more grams in a chimp.
They can't do things like that.
They can all throw rocks at the same time.
That's not rocket science.
But all the kinds of things that came next probably were enabled by that process
of us coming together and deciding to work together and cooperate.
So if you look at chimpanzees,
they don't cooperate very well.
Um,
for example,
one of the activities where they sorta cooperate is when the hunting monkeys and
so the law gather round and they'll see some monkeys in the trees and they'd
come in from every angle.
It's not very coordinated.
It's kind of a wild free for all.
But what's interesting about it is that when the Hunt's over,
let's say you just sat there the whole time and watched and I'm working my ass
off chasing these monkeys,
I got one.
You come up and bug me for it and I don't,
I don't really handle it.
You like keep nudging me til I share,
but I'm just as likely to share with you if you helped as if you didn't.
I don't make any distinction and you'll never establish effective groups if you
can't reward those who participate compared to those who don't.
Even little kids,
four year old kids,
when you give them games to play and they earn stickers,
if you didn't play,
you don't.
When you come up and ask,
you don't get an a,
you played even if you didn't do your job right,
but you tried,
boom,
you can have a sticker.
So humans immediately get that,
that you get rewarded for your activities as part of the group.
Chimps don't seem to have that.